okay
all right
once again
let's go
ladies and gentlemen
welcome back
[Music]
what's up y'all welcome back to ripping
with Griffin today obviously Super Bowl
you know I love talking about the NFL
right now because of the playoffs is so
good
[Music]
people keep using scientists are trying
to bring back extinct animals does that
sound dangerous and DC has released
their plan I don't know if I like it all
that and more on your podcast
[Music]
all right we're feeling ourselves today
it is what it is anyway
[Music]
and we are back with riffing with
Griffin welcome back to Griffin with
Griffin Eric griffin.com
worst website in the game but check it
out I got my tour dates and stuff like
that so make sure you check that out
thanks for subscribing guys I love that
you subscribe share you know uh you know
share this you know right now tweet it
out
tweet out you know hey this guy's live
right now check it out you're missing it
so subscribe share hit the notifications
so you know when I'm going live it's
usually sometime on Tuesday
all right uh twitch you know I'm on
Twitch daily I'm gonna be on Twitch
after this playing that Duty that Call
of Duty sometimes a little Fortnight but
uh mostly Call of Duty I love it and you
could be a subscriber on Twitch you
subscribe on Twitch you're supporting me
I appreciate it and that's where I also
do live patreon episodes and speaking of
you could be a patreon member if you
want to support me there you can you
could be a twitch subscriber patreon
subscriber YouTube member any of those
ways to support the show is awesome so I
appreciate that boom and just so you
know
um
uh if this weekend I would be in
Escondido in San Diego so you know if
you are in the San Diego area Escondido
I've been there before at the Grand
Comedy Club but another big show coming
up everybody
New York City NYC
New York
February 10th one night
get there let's do this one night New
York let's Galvanize the Eric Griffin
fans the riffin with Griffin fans
everybody that's about them
if you bought their woo-woos come on out
to the Bell House
tickets
in the profile
see you there
[Music]
all right yeah let's do a little
business
um
so anyways here we are guys what's going
on nothing really big to report this
week
um you know
nothing nothing major going on this week
in in the world in my world I'm saying
usually I got some kind of weird story
or something coming on uh but just
nothing really you know we just out here
you know I do my podcast once a week uh
regardless even if I feel like oh man I
don't know what's going on I got nothing
to talk about but you know here we are
so thanks for being here if you're in
the chat you got questions or something
like that you want to shout that out if
you have something I'll take a look at
the chat here because we're live so
thanks uh for everybody that's on here
live right now
um appreciate you guys
um
so yeah
catch me on most social media platforms
somebody said I like you on Snapchat you
know what weird I don't know if y'all
have uh if this happens to you on
Snapchat but I'm telling you man I keep
getting these
weird ass
bot
like it'll be like some girl right
it's not a real girl because it's a
quick ad you know it was somebody quick
at you and then you know they send me a
message and it's always the same thing
it's like all these messages and videos
and it's always something like you know
porn person or something like oh hey
they start a conversation that you're
not even even having a conversation you
they'll they'll have a like they're
having a conversation with themselves
hey uh where are you from oh my God
that's great well guess what I'm in your
area it's like wait I didn't even
respond like the bot the bot that what's
ever doing it is not even working
properly and this is always the same
thing and then just then it's a bunch of
nudity and all kinds of stuff and it's
just like like who does this work on
this is what I don't understand so I end
up having like every day I'm blocking
two people I'm blocking two of these
fake accounts why are these companies
allow still allow this
why even Instagram is allowing it you'll
have somebody with zero followers zero
posts
they're not they're they're no it's like
they're they're yeah zero post zero
followers they follow like whoever and
then they're and they're sending you a
DM uh hey it's like what who are you
it's starting some weird conversation
but Snapchat's the one right just go
what is that what like why is that still
happening and why is Snapchat still
allowing it I remember you guys remember
kick like kick was like I used to make
fun of that all the time because kick
somebody would start talking to you and
it it's clearly not a real person or
it's some you know weirdo in a you know
in a in a room full of porn people who
are like all right I got another one and
let's try to get them on this website
it's just so ridiculous what like I had
to stop using my WhatsApp because the
same thing was happening there they
those start conversations like this
they'll go they'll go like they'll say a
different name they'll be like hey David
uh it was good blah blah and then you're
supposed to respond
Otis isn't David and then they go oh
really oh my God I'm so sorry you know I
love meeting new people hey what about
it's like does that ain't gonna
work what do you think I was born
yesterday
so stupid man so I don't know so like I
don't even know if Kick's even a thing
anymore so I deleted Kick I'm close to
deleting freaking Snapchat just because
of like it's so it's like all now I see
it you know it's like it's just there
dude
like it's so there you know what I mean
like you go you go to Snapchat and then
if you go to like the the ad friends one
it's clearly like you know and I've even
seen it by it says by search so now I'm
like are these is this porn company
whoever these people are are they
specifically searching for me oh hey add
that guy maybe they know I'm talking
about this or something but it's so
ridiculous so you just you know you
block the the thing and it's just like
there's never so I don't even know who
the real people are anymore I just I
don't know who the real people are
anymore I don't it doesn't even
um
make any sense you know what I mean it
don't even make any sense so somebody
said are we getting the boys review is
there a new season of the boys already
I didn't miss that did I no
the shows I'm watching right now which
I'll review I'm reviewing the new season
of Hunter on on on
um
on Amazon Prime that's one of the shows
I'm watching right now I'm watching uh
Hunters that's a really great show Al
Pacino and a bunch of people it's about
it's like in the 70s or something like
it's like a maybe late early 70s
whatever these are like some some Nazi
Hunters
and Hitler's still alive and they're
trying to get him uh okay so that's what
that show's about and then I'm watching
the new season of Jack Ryan
it's a little cheesy but I'm watching
that of course as you know I'm watching
Last of Us so I'm gonna have some more
some more episodes go before I uh talk
about last of us and then I'm also
watching uh the servant on Apple TV I
don't know if you're watching this show
but this season is weird shout out to my
comic buddy Justin Martindale we both
love watching the servant so we'll talk
about that I don't know so talk about
that next week or in coming weeks for
that those are the shows yeah those are
the shows I'm watching uh right now what
else
um I'm trying to think if there's
another show no that's that's really it
there's not that many because then all
the good shows are coming out again
succession is coming out
um yeah I don't know uh you know I it's
funny I haven't finished the the this
season of White Lotus I've seen in the
chat right now having uh yeah I haven't
finished this season of White Lotus oh
book club
book club people if you are you know
interested in the books that I read all
you guys I gotta I got a new
book for you
um Mission Clockwork the complete series
yeah the mission Clockwork uh this is
one of these authors I I like
um what's his name wait author Slade his
name is Arthur Slade and he wait what is
let me look at his
I gotta look at his thing
yeah because he's a pretty good this
guy's a pretty good author and he has
this other book that I really liked
um
yeah so if you're into book club
remember my my main guy I like to push a
lot is Christopher uh Nuttall so check
out Christopher Nuttall really good
author I love that all right so let's
see oh yeah so yeah Dragon assassin yeah
that was the books I was reading from
this guy author Slade yeah so he wrote
this book Dragon assassin but he's got
this oh wait where's this by man you
know you Google somebody man you go to
their their their website and you're
just like damn this dude got a lot of
got a lot of books yeah so this guy's
got a lot of books so I'm about to check
him out sometimes I'm gonna get into an
author you like their style and you're
like you know what I'm gonna keep uh
I'm gonna check this out
yeah so this um
yeah he's kind of a fantasy writer but
this Clockwork
this Clockwork uh book whatever it's
called Mission Clockwork it's a whole
series you know it's kind of it's kind
of based in
um
England and it's about like Espionage so
it's about these spies in that in like
early early early
stages you know like I don't know it's
like
pre-World War one or something like that
I can't really figure out the you know
they still got horses and stuff like
that going on but at the same time like
technology is advancing so there's a
little bit of mysticism in it because
they got like Jekyll and Hyde in it it's
like that Universe you know anyways the
guy's a great author and I like how I
like how their story flows so anyways
that's uh what's what's coming up guys
that's what's coming up all right so I
want to get right into
um I want to get right into the NFL
because the Super Bowl is coming I am a
huge Super Bowl fan I love the Super
Bowl like I go to Vegas every year with
my boy
shout out to my boy Jeff we go to we've
been going to Vegas every year for the
Super Bowl I think we've only missed
like one year but I'm talking about
going back 20 years or something we just
go to Vegas now we're old so it's so
funny we'll go to Vegas we'll be down in
the sports book and then we'll be
looking at the game and then we go up to
the room and we're watching the second
half of the game and we fall asleep
during the third quarter
you know and we
will be the game forgot to go make other
bets uh so that's uh where we're at with
that so
but anyways here we are what uh what a
championship Sunday we had it was
exciting
disappointing on so many levels it was
disappointing so let's start with the
most disappointing thing is
these aren't my picks okay so I picked
the Bengals to win and I picked the
49ers to win so I'm disappointed but I
did say that any one of these teams is
deserving of going to the Super Bowl and
winning these are those were the four
best teams I thought
so let's start and it was disappointing
all the way around though officiating
was disappointing some of the gameplay
was disappointing especially in the
49ers Eagles game 49ers Eagles game was
that was probably the most disappointing
game of the last like I don't know how
many years because you're talking about
Clash of the Titans the number one
defense number one but two number one
and number two defenses they had great
offenses you had the best team all year
with the best record you had uh you know
a MVP candidate final two MVP candidate
going up against this Juggernaut of uh
defense and their offense into shabby
either with all of the the the
you know uh Pro Bowl candidates I
believe it was something like 14 of the
total of all the Pro Bowl candidates
were in this game so we were expecting a
barn burner you had this rookie third
round pick last pick in the draft seven
game winning streak going into you know
can he can he be the first rookie to go
to the Super Bowl and then you had Jalen
Hurst year two best record in the league
you know what's he gonna do and the
whole thing was disappointing okay
terrible calls by the officials Brock
Purdy gets hurt and he gets really hurt
like more now we know more her he's
gonna be out six months that's how hurt
he was
six six plays into the game they have no
quarterback then they put in this guy
who was not prepared Johnson I think
it's Jack Johnson or whatever his name
is he wasn't ready he gets knocked out
he gets a concussion he can't go back in
the game then they got Christian
McCaffrey who's who's now the next
quarterback in line they have to bring
Purdy back in he can't even throw the
ball it was just the most disappointing
debacle of the uh you know of the thing
you know and then cut to also the Eagles
not looking all that great
uh you know the San Francisco's defense
was still out there balling and so you
know the Eagles had turnovers but their
offense didn't really look like um is
this offense gonna be able to get it
done you know so
it was disappointing
Eagles won that's not disappointing that
the Eagles won though disappointing for
me personally because I thought the
49ers would do it but I'm still glad
that the Eagles went because they were
the best team all year jalenhurst has
had a great story you know he comes back
from all the adversity that he's gone
through in his career in his life uh you
know being cut being taken out of the me
being being replaced in the championship
game having to go to another school
fight his way back win the Heisman now
you know he you know so many people
didn't even want him to be drafted by
the Eagles you know they were like boo I
hope we don't ever get to that guy now
he's like looking like a franchise
quarterback
so kudos to the eagles they made it to
the Super Bowl it's disappointing at the
49ers season finished the way it did and
now I hear they just lost their
defensive coordinator damico Ryan's who
had you know the last two years have
been the best defense in the league for
two years in a row he went over to
Houston so who knows what the food who
the 49ers are going to get to keep that
defense rolling now on the other side
also disappointing
some bad calls in that game too I
thought also very disappointed because
one Patrick Holmes wasn't a hundred
percent even though he was Superman in
this game though so he's cementing his
legacy as being like top five
quarterback of all time you know he
really is putting himself in that
category he just if he gets more Super
Bowls even if you don't get to Seven
like Tom Brady he gets two or three more
we gonna be like that's the best
quarterback of all time we can see it
you know what I mean uh most
accomplished will always be Tom Brady
but this dude is on he different okay
Patrick Holmes is different so you got
the Bengals who I thought have already
beaten them three times in a row uh Joe
burrow is looking like that dude
Cincinnati's talking a lot of smack I
mean the game was back and forth but it
wasn't a high scoring game like we
thought the defense has actually showed
up for the like it was it was more of a
defensive battle than even the other
game you know because the Eagles still
scored 30 something points you know what
I mean so this was like a deep defensive
battle with these two Juggernaut
quarterbacks top two three quarterbacks
in the league playing right now
um but Joe Bro didn't show up man he he
didn't he wasn't he wasn't MVP you know
it wasn't Borough time in this game he
had a couple of costly interceptions
uh you know those three hurt offensive
linemen it showed up in this game and
you know and then they just couldn't
stop patching my homes you know and I
just feel like this is where I feel like
Joe burrow let let the Cincinnati
Bengals down
they had two minutes like a little over
two minutes left with two timeouts two
minute warning to go down score and win
the game and they couldn't get it done
it's either go down kick a field goal go
down score touchdown win the game or
send it to overtime but whatever you do
don't give the ball back to Patrick
Mahomes okay he didn't get that done
that's where Cincinnati let down they
were let down by the offense because the
defense did their job they held the
Chiefs only scored what 20 something
points 21 22 whatever it was so
I was disappointed in Cincinnati's
gameplay
um but
the Chiefs kudos to them I mean the dude
lost three of his starting receivers in
this game a couple of defensive injuries
in this game out and he literally put
the team on his back on one foot because
he aggravated that ankle and 300
something yards two touchdowns the dude
is cementing himself as he's gonna win
the MVP so boom all right now cut to now
we have this Super Bowl matchup
some history in the making youngest
quarterbacks to ever
youngest combined age of quarterbacks in
the Super Bowl
two black quarterbacks starting
this the first time that's ever happened
you know what I mean and what I like too
is like it's too light-skinned uh oh
light skin is the right skin
just kidding you know you know I like
these I'm a mix I'm a mixed baby so when
I see these mixed quarterbacks I'm like
we doing it for the mix so we in the mix
um but I don't know actually I don't
know Jalen Brown's mix he's just a fair
complexion and you know what I mean he's
not Wesley Snipes you know what I'm
saying he like 6 30 instead of midnight
um
so this is going to be an epic matchup
because now we have this really great
defense that's left number two number
one they were they were they were back
and forth with San Francisco as the best
defense in the league they have a
tremendous offensive line they have a
tremendous defensive line
um I don't know I don't know who I'm
picking I'm probably gonna wait till
next week before I pick my Super Bowl
but let's see right now I'm right now
I'm leaning towards this how can you bet
against uh
um
Patrick Mahomes now because they already
did it he was they were you know they
were the underdog at home so I don't
know I I feel like is this his time you
know they've been to five straight AFC
championships this will be the third
Super Bowl appearance he has one Super
Bowl win
like this is incredible what's happening
right now if he wins this Super Bowl and
even if he doesn't if he got a career
ending injury he would still be Hall of
Fame that's how great his five-year
career has been so
right now I'm leaning Kansas City Chiefs
but I gotta say
the Eagles are this is one of the best
teams ever to be in the Super Bowl I'm
talking about the roster from top to
bottom is absolutely fantastic at every
single position they have depth
Hall of Famers pro bowlers so
it's tough but again you're talking
about Patrick Mahomes versus this
complete team so we will see
you know what I mean we'll see
we will see so anyways Super Bowl we're
done with the Super Bowl
put my football talk for this week for
you guys that don't like football talk
but you know you appreciate how I talk
about it I appreciate you
if you have any questions in the chat
I'll be more than happy to you know
actually let me put one of those things
up what is this uh
uh they they usually oh here we go here
we go here we go you go engage with your
audience oh here we go start a q a
what you got
questions
all right so I'll start that
q a thing right there
so whatever
let me know if you got something
okay anyways all right what's next all
right let's talk about some stuff some
news and notes shout out to my girl
Kristen uh Espinoza my my producer she
helps me out with a lot of stuff She'll
always send me great topics of things to
talk about so for the Nerds uh you know
I'm into Marvel I'm into superheroes I'm
into fantasy so apparently you know how
they got James Gunn is uh you know James
Gunn is over at DC now man and so they
he put out the official slate of they
put out the official state of movies
that are coming to
uh coming to the new DCU universe so you
know that's what I call the MCU they had
the DCU movie so so they got Superman
Legacy
um it's written by gun
uh so I don't know what this is gonna be
about but according to the thing it says
Superman Legacy will allow Khalil as he
we we can reconciles his
extraterrestrial Origins with his human
family and upbringing it sounds like a
reboot of Man of Steel yeah director
yeah yeah because I remember Man of
Steel
um then they go this other the next
one's called The Authority the superhero
Ensemble dates to 1999 comic Authority
is a group of seven Heroes with very
high concept superpowers okay so I don't
know I don't know about that one
Supergirl woman of tomorrow so you know
all right Supergirl is always a good
story I remember the Supergirl movie
back in the day it's cheesy as hell but
you know I still watched it I liked it
Swamp Thing wow they bring a swamp thing
back
so those are the movies then they got
the TV shows they're talking about which
will probably go to HBO Max
uh Creature Commandos I don't know what
the hell that is Waller
well they CA they keep that Amanda
Waller's story is going in all these
movies man so who knows I don't see
anything about Black Adam 2 you know
this is all crazy lanterns so this is a
the Green Lantern story obviously
there's gonna be a Paradise Lost and and
God knows who else what else is going on
you know and then and then uh you know
as I talk about this James Gunn I guess
he's like because James Gunn was the guy
he did all those
um
he was he was the Marvel guy for a while
right you know so
I mean it's cool
you know he's he's a better filmmaker
but he's really shaking things up you
know it's like they want to get a new
Superman a new Batman and new all this
stuff and he just kind of like wait we
have to go through this again it's like
our minds are already fractured with DC
because of how Marvel is Marvel is very
consistent it's like here's Thor here's
Spider-Man here's all the heroes they're
not gonna change maybe the movies won't
be as good but we have a consistency
within the universe
with DC man you got a you got two
Batmans now because you got the you know
the the this new Batman franchise with
you know uh uh Pat Patterson you know
what I mean and then you got a joker
they're coming out with that so you got
that series
and it's nothing's connected so we had
this is like taking us back to the way
we were before but we have to like
fracture our brains and be like
compartment compartmentalize that this
is a separate universe but we've gotten
so used to having the universes be
um you know combined we like that well
at least I like it what do you guys
think in the chats in the comments I
mean do you like that you know I do I
like separate Universe man you know
I like
I I'm not separate I like the combined
universe and you know the movies are all
and even in the TV shows because even
with Marvel you're talking about the
movies the TV shows they're all
connected you know we had She-Hulk and
you had these like appearances by people
from the movie I love that I don't know
what's happening with DC man I don't
know I don't know how they're gonna I
don't know how they're gonna make this
happen so we'll see
and but you know do you believe in James
Gunn you know what I mean
I mean I I feel like he could be the one
you know oh and I still got that silly
Flash movie that with this crazy actor
that has been through so much turmoil
are they even coming out with that are
they are they using that to set up other
things like Wonder Woman and Aquaman and
like what's going on with all this you
know I like the Wonder Woman I like uh
Gal Gadot or whatever her name is I
liked her
she's Wonder Woman to me now I think
she's gone
um I even got used to the dude that
played Superman and he's gone it's like
I don't know what's going on
um
yeah they go James Gunn says Henry
cavizel I thought you say his name Kate
whatever Henry Cavite whatever
how do you say his name whatever I know
that guy that sent me emails could be
like Griffin be prepared
but you know the guy I'm talking about
the guy playing Superman Henry he wasn't
fired just not hired that's the this one
article I just saw was a fire just not
hired like what
like we like him
I don't know
I don't know if I like it and then
they're doing this other thing where I
saw this I saw this uh I don't know if
you guys heard about how Batgirl
Batgirl Fallout from Batgirl's
cancellation is only the beginning and
then this article says an anonymous star
of the film says Warner Brothers CEO
David zalavs
cowardice is breathtaking
like what does that even mean
so apparently there was some whole thing
about you know this Batgirl movie you
guys should Google it to see what's
going on according to the New York Post
which first broke the news earlier this
month the DC outing which was originally
set to hit HBO Max sometime this year
won't go anywhere not in theaters not on
streaming the film which reportedly cost
somewhere in the ballpark of 90 million
dollars to make and was even close to
wrapping post-production is officially
going to the the sad state of limbo
where their Snyder cut once lived it's a
shame because they superhero
starred Leslie Grace and Barbara Gordon
Batgirl Michael Keaton as Batman and
Brendan Frazier as the villain Firefly
oh man they were bringing Michael Keaton
back I didn't even know that wow
wow
the decision to not release Batgirl
reflects our leadership stretch
strategic shift as it relates to DC
Universe and HBO Max what is this what
does all this even mean you know they
write these articles and you just kind
of want to go what does it mean like why
did you cancel this movie
I don't know
that's a weird that's a weird thing
because uh I like I I like Doom Patrol
I like that on HBO Max because it used
to be on DC Universe because I remember
that was a streaming service that I got
I liked it actually I liked uh DC
because you can see you could read
comics and stuff on it but they got rid
of it and so they put all their DC stuff
on and then Teen Titans I like Teen
Titans because it's like rated R uh you
know so it's like you know rated R rated
R Robin but it's a little cheesy the
acting's corny so it's like I don't know
if either one of these shows are that
well made I mean I think Doom Patrol is
a much better show I think it's writing
and acting I think but even that show is
a little bit like disjointed you're just
kind of like what is this really about
and where is it going I mean I think
that's the question with DC is like
where is it going where's it going like
you know at least because even and by
the way and this is the same thing with
Marvel too I don't know where it's going
I believe they're making more Avengers
and all that stuff and I'm hearing
they're bringing Tony Stark back Janine
you got to just be a member you don't
got to do this every week appreciate you
so much though
um it's another Super Chat coming in
hard man coming in hot
um
but the D but like even with Marvel I'm
not sure where it's going they're kind
of like they shot their wad with endgame
and they're like okay now what and
they're trying to keep it going but at
least we know we have like a base
understanding a foundation of what the
Marvel universe is DC I don't know what
the hell they're doing there's this sort
of like secret underworld of Amanda
Waller who only runs this sort of weird
organization government organization so
that's like the base Foundation because
she seems to be in every freaking movie
you know and it's all about her and like
you know you know there's a prison and
they had a you know what was the one
with uh uh um
come on what's the other movie with uh
the girl that they had birds of prey
with uh um why am I forgetting I'm
getting so old guys you guys are going
to know in a chat just tell me Harley
Quinn like they had the whole Harley
Quinn stuff and then they had the other
Joker with uh it's it's just like what
is happening that's basically kept
saying
so
if they're gonna put out James Gunn is
going to clean sweep everything and
start over then I'm like okay then just
do that
get rid of all of it get rid of all of
it Ben Affleck's Batman
Aquaman Wonder Woman Superman get rid of
all of them cyborg flash you go hey
we're scrapping that whole thing it was
trash it was garbage we failed you we're
gonna start over do that
that statement out
you know and then I'll be like okay let
me see what you got
The Suicide Squad thank you The Suicide
Squad
the fact that they had two of them and
they were different just made me be like
what is this that's my whole point I
don't know what this is so they had that
and then they had the Harley Quinn and
then they had the other move it's like I
don't know what's happening
Margot Robbie is a great Harley Quinn
but then that got weird
you know it's just like what is this
like make I think they're cartoon Harley
Quinn is better than the movie version I
don't know if you've ever seen the
cartoon Harley Quinn that's that suck
that's a funny
cartoon
shout out to my boy Ron funches who
plays the shark in that
um so I don't know I don't know about DC
you tell me what you think in the chat
you know it's like DC do you like the
direction you think they're gonna go is
James Gunn the right choice or or you
know is Marvel
you know it's Marvel wear
it's or just you know you like Marvel
better or you think they're both like
they're both trash and they haven't they
both aren't figuring it out properly you
know what I mean so I don't know guys
um let me look at some comments real
quick
I had somebody with I had to use my
phone for my music so I so I got all
messed up here
oh okay
Mary H love Eric I love the way you talk
to Rachel you're so funny with her and
Rachel I love you too thank you Mary H
she's that was like only six hours ago
um my boy Matt Rife is like blowing up
you know I had him on the podcast a long
time ago but now he's like super blowing
up he's blowing up so much he asked me
to go do a show with him so now I gotta
go open for him my career's over
um let's see
let's see what we got here uh
uh so so I I was talking about last of
us and people are going in on me on Last
of Us like I said I didn't I didn't like
the pilot you know and then I was like I
felt like I don't know if they're what
they're doing with the budget but it
doesn't look it don't look as great as I
would like it to look and then somebody
uh groov gamer said you know last of us
has the most toxic fan base ever The
Fanboys flip out unless you say it's the
best game ever made this you know the
story is fine but hard to be uh to be
the best when the gameplay is so
mediocre yeah so like there's like some
hardcore Last of Us fans in my chat
going off like there was this one idiot
who was like I was like I don't know
what the budget he was like well I'm out
because it was the it was the most
expensive show of all time it was like
so I had to go look I had to go fact
check this idiot and guess what Last of
Us isn't even close to being the most
expensive show of all time now it's
expensive apparently they're spending 10
million dollars an episode and when I
look at it I go on what so I don't know
maybe that's salaries and stuff because
I feel like I don't feel like the
special effects is all that great I
don't I don't believe the like the
universe to me isn't set up but the
show's great this last episode of Last
of Us was it was beautiful it was a
beautiful episode that's all I'll say so
watch the second at the third is this
that third I think it's the third
episode of The Last of Us really it was
really magnificent anyways
it's like House of dragons is like 20
million an episode last few seasons of
Game of Thrones
uh was 15 million
the all the Marvel shows
are 20 million plus per episode it's
it's crazy
um
yeah man I see some comments in the chat
like when you watch Last of Us aren't
you looking like okay like like it some
of the stuff don't make sense to me it's
like you know this is supposed to be 20
years after this sort of zombie
apocalypse
and like no no there wouldn't be stuff
in the stores I'm sorry there wouldn't
be any hidden compartments anymore
everything has been should be looted
there shouldn't be glasses
anyways it's just it's crazy to me so it
looks I get what they're trying to do
with the look but to me it's a little
disjointed you know it doesn't flow the
way I feel like it should but they're
worried more about the story which they
did a fantastic job in episode three so
that's what I'm saying they departed
from the game story and they went into
episode three and it's just like a great
way to show how this universe progressed
it was just it's really beautiful anyway
it's a great episode if you're if you
have a soul you'll cry
um so anyways you know DC I don't know
what you're doing figure figure your
crap out man you know figure it out
all right let's see what else do I got
on the Slate here all right so we talked
about Batgirl we talked about James Gunn
um
so here's a crazy story dude
let's look at this
this D extension extent Extinction
company will try to bring back the dodo
bird
colossal bioscience also intends to
resurrect The Woolly Mammoth and
whatever it's an ambitious agenda
considering no extinct species has ever
been brought back
okay what are we doing
like this sounds very clony this sounds
very Jurassic Park this sounds like
we're going down a rabbit hole
[Laughter]
and we're gonna end up with a T-Rex
stomping down Hollywood Boulevard you
know eating people coming out of movies
like what are we talking about right
so I you know
I don't know about this
I mean I don't but my my thought when I
saw this I started to think like well
this is just like part of the science
but anytime I see this I think okay so
is this is this like where we go with
like cloning and
you know extending people's lives and
like like where does this all go where
does it lead to I mean if you can bring
bring back extinct species
I mean how does that even work and they
apparently got some sort of 150 million
dollar Grant to do more research you
know it's like you know that I mean
Science and Technology like we're
getting towards the the science fiction
that we thought about when we watched
movies or we read certain types of books
like this stuff is become coming to life
man you know it's like I always think
about the cloning because I have a buddy
of mine who had a heart transplant you
know so I think about like
I think about the ability to grow your
own Limbs and organs for a transplant is
that possible is it a way now to like
you know that is that is that where
we're going with it but then that turns
into like you know any any evil science
fiction movie it turns into always turns
into something bizarre but there are
great advances and things that could be
done right so I don't know is this is
this where it goes like we bring back
the woolly mammoth like where is that
where's that gonna live so we just
gonna bring back a dinosaur creature and
just be like all right yeah y'all can
you know and what about the other
animals who've just been like wait a
willy Mammoth is back you know the other
elephants are gonna be like hold on
is that our cousin you know like what
are we supposed to do with this dude so
I don't know
I don't know what's going on with that
I don't know what's going on with it I
don't know what how I feel about it but
it does make it I don't know if it gives
me hope or it gives me pause what do you
guys think I mean when you hear about
this what do you think you know they're
always trying to science is always
trying to figure out like like one of
the things they're trying to figure out
is like you know when you're a baby
there's some sort of like mechanism in
our in our workup that we grow our arms
and legs because there's a part of us
that grows
into a human form and then it stops
then it stops you know and then we just
get bigger but we're not growing anymore
if that makes sense so I think
scientists are still trying to figure
out how can the human body turn that
back on so if we lose an arm we could
grow it back
so like there's there's all that man
there's all that sort of like weird
uh you know sciency thinking going on
but I think we're making great advances
in science since you know we the whole
world had to like come up with a vaccine
to you know save people or whatever you
think about that I don't care I'm not
going to get into that I'm just saying
that push for science from something
like that happens more advancements
start to happen so we'll see I think
there's going to be a lot of great stuff
because you know for me personally for
me personally you know my mom has
dementia man and there's been a lot of
stuff about dementia and Alzheimer's in
the last like six months that is really
hopeful you know they're really starting
to like delve into this and really start
to discover some things about it that
who knows maybe they're a few years away
from a cure or a few years away from it
slowing it down tremendously or finding
out their causes and knocking that out
so
you know man it's it's uh who knows
where we're going with that and so this
story really made me think about I think
about that that okay so now we're
starting with bringing back extinct
animals
and you know I don't even know how the
process works so we'll see where this
goes I mean there's so much sciency
stuff going on that if you're not into
it you'll never hear about it you don't
even know what's going there's so much
information in the world right now about
stuff that it's just we're being
distracted by nonsense man but there's
you know if you just look at what's
going on in the Science World what's
going on and even Financial world what's
going on you know there's so many things
that you know we just we don't stay up
on now because it's information overload
and so now we just cultivate and curate
our entertainment and information to the
things that only the things that we want
to hear about sometimes that's good news
sometimes it's conspiracy stuff or
sometimes it's very specific to just
whatever you like but man I'm telling
you open up your brains and minds and uh
and look into some of these things that
are going on it's pretty crazy
pretty crazy like they say that colossal
intends to produce a willy mammoth from
an artificial womb I mean you start with
animals
and it goes from animals to people you
know I just there's no way they're not
thinking about
making people in an artificial womb I
mean what if that was the way you had
babies
you know what I mean like you just
you know you had your your wife's eggs
they took your stuff and they had some
artificial womb that you didn't have to
like the woman didn't have to deal with
pregnancy
I don't know they got surrogates already
so maybe the surrogate could be a
machine now an artificial womb think
about all that think about where we're
going scary stuff
um and now staying with science here's
something that's crazy you know this is
some Hollywood nonsense that's going on
is
you know people can't get their diabetes
medication
because ozempic people can't get their
diabetes medication because people are
using it as a popular weight loss Aid
like what are we doing man so of course
if you're a company that makes this
stuff you're like oh we're making this
life-saving stuff oh but wait a minute
rich people want to use it people that
got disposable income want to use it to
uh
lose weight
they say Olympic works by mimicking a
hormone in the body that regulates
insulin levels it's a type of drug
called glp-1 the medication is
self-administered weekly as an injection
Okay so
that is a shortage of it
there's a shortage
so imagine you in line at the pharmacy
trying to get your diabetes medications
because so you don't die
and some you know blonde
white girl is in front of you like I'm
here for myself because you know what I
mean I you know
I gotta get my summer body you know it's
like what
I don't I don't even
like what are we talking about man
so
I mean first of all I have a problem
with
life-saving medications being for profit
anyway it's like insulin and that kind
of stuff you just go come on man should
somebody be making a billion dollars off
insulin it's like whoever created that
they made it because we had this need it
saves lives and now you want to be like
no I'm gonna save your life if you pay
me
oh no look I'm not super liberal about
stuff like this normally but there are
certain things like it's like you know
when we're going to get to the point
when the water wars start and we have to
pay for like water we already have water
bills we literally do have to pay for
water but like to the point where you
could get water right there's no there's
no way you like imagine though when
water is scarce and you have to actually
pay for water but if you don't get water
you'll die
right so we're gonna get to that point
what if we controlled water like that
food and yeah there's people out here I
guess there's places in the world that
don't have clean water don't have a lot
of you know food and here we are with
life-saving medication and people who
just are lazy to lose weight are using
it for that
it's it's it's crazy right
I don't know
you know it's like there's certain
things I always say that I don't think
should be for profit I don't think
education should be for profit I don't
think Health Care should be for profit
you know
Healthcare education and there was
another one
I forgot but those are the two main ones
I'm tired had a long day those are the
two main ones guys you know education
like if somebody's making a billion
dollars if there's some millionaire
sitting there I mean maybe the school
should make the money to to to to
research and what I'm just saying the
money should filter back into itself it
shouldn't be like we should all be
educated so it's like you know people
that want to get education they should
be allowed to go get education but it's
turned into this like money grubbing
business that I just don't understand I
don't know
you guys know what I'm talking about
here on Riverwood Griffin
here on riffing with Griffin so ozempic
will keep you posted about that
yeah prisons shouldn't be for profit
either right what are we talking about
you know I I there should be a profit
but I don't think somebody should be
getting like generational wealth off
those type of things one person
that's really what I'm trying to say
because it's like well what is this
about
you know what I mean it's like what are
we doing this for you know
so
I don't know
anyways guys
remember I'm gonna be in the Bell House
in Brooklyn
February 10th so come check that out if
you're in San Diego Escondido area I'll
see you this weekend at the Grand comedy
club uh but once again look at my
website I got a bunch of dates coming up
but one of the big ones is I'm I'm just
I'm trying to get people to come see me
in New York all right if you're in New
York you want to see me live come check
me out I am hilarious uh on stage guys
I'm telling you right now it was my
calling was to be a stand-up comedian so
come check me out wherever I'm coming to
your city you will have a good time who
this person that I am right here is like
it's so it's like this is one aspect of
my personality where I'm introspective
and I like to talk about things and I
like to like get into depth about stuff
and and then it's just I when I'm on
stage it's a whole different animal
that's a whole other character too as
opposed to also when I'm in a podcast
with other people it's like so weird I
have all these levels of my personality
but one of the ones I I love the most is
my stand up so come check me out live
okay you know what that means it's the
rap recap
did it again
I'm so cute so you fat fat
Super Bowl preview
thought you do
[Music]
see you next week
what does that mean
ah I'm getting late
definitely
look at that forehead no shame
[Music]
from my head to my feet
and if you wanna send a beat email me at
Eric Griffin
[Music]
where are we
can't see it next week I'll be back
[Music]